So to be able to move
between different states,
we need a MediaPlayer object that is
initialized for a certain audio file.
Then we can call methods on that
object to move between the states.
So we created a MediaPlayer object by
calling the MediaPlayer.create method.
Notice that this is
using a factory method
instead of a constructor
to create our object.
If you recall from the last course,
we learned about factory methods
as another way to create objects.
And so for example,
to create a toast message object,
we've already been using
the Toast.makeText factory method.
So to clarify, when you call the static
method, you call on the class.
And remember, that has to be
exact name of the Java class.
Now when you call a regular method or
one that's not declared as static,
you can call the method on
an object instance of the class.
So this name can change depending on
the name of your object variable.
To learn more details about
media playback on Android,
I highly recommend Ian Lake's talk,
titled media playback the right way,
that he gave at
the Big Android BBQ conference.
You can find the link for it down below.
In the developer documentation for
MediaPlayer, the create methods are
shown here in the public method section.
So the choice to use a factory
method versus a constructor
in order to create new objects was
decided by the original developer
who wrote out this MediaPlayer code.
Instead of having different constructors
on the MediaPlayer class, the developer
chose to have different create methods
that could have different sets of
parameters depending on if you want to
play an audio file included in the app,
or stream that audio from another
data source like the Internet.
So in our case, we use this constructor.
So create and it takes in context
context, and res id of type integer.
So we call this create method and
pass in its two inputs.
So the current context and the resource
id for the file that we want to play,
and the return value of this method
is a brand new media player object.
So you may have noticed here that
the create method is a static method.
Just like how static variables belong to
a class and not to individual instances,
static methods are methods that
are bound to the class itself.
So one neat advantage of this is
that we can call the methods without
ever making an instance of the class.
Now if we return back to the media
player API guide, in the code here,
we can call the static method like this.
So we can use the exact name
of the class MediaPlayer and
not need to use the name
of an object variable.
We can use the same dot operator that
we would use on an instance, and
then follow it with the name
of the static method.
So we pass in the context and
the resource identifier for
the sound file that we want to play.
So the MediaPlayer needs a context in
order to access shared resources on
the device and to know what
environment it's being used in.
And after that, we can tell the media
player to begin playback by calling
it's start method.
So note that this comment here points
that there's no need to call the prepare
method explicitly because
the create method
already helps us prepare
the audio file for us.
So we can call a create method and
then immediately call the start method.
And after that,
we can call other MediaPlayer methods.